it is great to have back on the program
bobby azarian who's a cognitive
neuroscientist blogger for psychology
today and whose new book is the romance
of reality how the universe organizes
itself to create life consciousness and
cosmic complexity bobby great uh
speaking to you again
thanks for having me back david so i
mean the book is fascinating because it
starts with these are just big topics
right how what what are the origins of
life what is what is consciousness what
is sort of our place how do we
understand our ability to perceive and
understand but it also has very much
real world kind of day-to-day
nitty-gritty implications about how we
solve individual problems political
questions how people relate to each
other how we understand what is real and
what is not real and kind of
epistemology can you talk just like
generally what was the main point you
wanted to get across in the book
so yeah there are a lot of points that
you mentioned
but the general idea is that uh
so it's i guess to contrast it to the
old paradigm the old paradigm uh the
kind of reigning scientific worldview
was known as the reductionist paradigm
and it basically says that life is
something of a cosmic accident and that
life is transient and has no larger
cosmic significance
but the story that's emerging from
complexity sciences challenging that
it basically says that the universe
isn't getting increasingly disordered as
once thought it's getting more and more
complex
and life is a part of that
complexification process and once life
emerges it becomes the driver of that
process
so
we're not an accident we are a natural
manifestation of the laws of physics and
the evolutionary dynamics that emerge
from those laws
and this means that life has something
like a purpose
in the universe and that's to see that
life continues to persist and spread
throughout the cosmos so what's
fascinating about that to put to pause
there is
if people
listen to ninety percent but not a
hundred percent of what you're saying
they might misunderstand what you're
saying as meaning either one
that there is
purpose in the way that some attribute
to religion or god which is not what
you're saying here you're saying that
the purpose of life is is to persist
life wants to continue so so to speak
and number two if people listen to 90
but not 100 of what you're saying they
might think you're saying that the
pre-existing ideas for example about
entropy are being contradicted by what
you're saying but you're not really
you're you're sort of
expanding on that uh in in a sense if i
understand correctly
yeah so to address those two points
let's start with the entropy point first
there's a lot of confusion about what
the second law of thermodynamics means
yes and uh there's a statistical
interpretation of that law that
basically says that ordered systems will
naturally move
toward a more disordered state
and uh that that's true for closed
systems so closed systems are systems
that aren't open to energy coming in
from an outside source
so the planet earth is an open system
and that is because we have a star we
have our sun
that is radiating all this energy down
on the planet and those energy flows uh
basically uh organize
life
and uh we so
energy flowing through a simple chemical
system will organize it and that is the
mechanism that creates life
on a planet so the idea
basically is that life can continue to
persist against this tendency towards
disorder as long as it can continue to
extract energy from the environment
because the energy is used to sustain
itself
but uh in using that energy
it uses up ordered energy and it
dissipates that energy as heat and that
creates entropy too so complexity can
grow and grow and grow if life can
spread and find more energy and the
second law of thermodynamics really just
says that there's an energetic cost to
creating order that you have to use some
of this
available energy and
basically turn that energy into entropy
so it doesn't violate the second law
unless you think the second law
applies to the whole universe and says
that the universe is growing
increasingly disordered
this challenges that and says we need to
understand that entropy is this complex
term it takes on a number of forms
and that life uh doesn't have to be
transient if we can
solve our problems and continue
to extract energy
then
we can persist
the religious purpose that is often
debated by
christian apologists and others you're
talking about purpose in a different way
and and it makes intuitive sense if you
think about for example um
uh
evolution right and the idea well when
we when we talk about purpose you could
say the purpose here is evolution is
fueling
more fit species so that they can
continue to live so that life persists
as you're talking about we don't have to
talk about purpose ideologically
necessarily or as a designed thing and
still acknowledge that maybe purpose
could be an appropriate word in terms of
life wanting to preserve and continue
yes so uh there was a big movement to
kind of get purpose out of biology in
the 20th century right but we're
understanding that uh purpose or agency
uh is really the defining characteristic
of life so if you compare life to an
inanimate object like a rock or a chair
those things don't do anything
interesting and if they move if a rock
you know
tumbles down a hill it's because of the
force of gravity or
if you see a rock moving on the street
it's being pushed by a gust of wind but
life
moves
according to survival goals
so it has agency and this agency is
basically
a product of the information stored in
living systems which are adaptive
systems
so
it's really helpful to talk about
purpose but if you zoom out and you look
at the universe and you understand that
life uh isn't any sort of
uh magical
uh it doesn't have some sort of magical
ingredient propelling it
then you see that uh the inanimate
matter in the universe is waking up uh
in the form of life and so you don't see
it so much as just life trying to
persist you see it as the universe sort
of waking up uh through life and being
able to experience itself
so there are some big uh what i would
call spiritual implications of this
theory uh but it is an entirely
mechanistic
naturalistic picture because we can
understand these uh processes that
generate complexity
we can formalize them with mathematics
so
there's no magic in this framework
however i will say it is still really
mysterious why the universe is so
fine-tuned
to give rise to life and if you uh
believe the argument in this book
it doesn't just allow life it
necessitates life and basically ensures
that life will continue to adapt and
spread
so now in in along those lines
when we look at societies and the way
that
human society is organized we can find
lots of relatively persistent you know
i'm talking here about hundreds of years
which is still a relatively small amount
of time but but it's modern society we
see lots of mechanisms that seem like
they would run counter to that right uh
world wars for example um the
seeking and obtaining of nuclear weapons
which you know it's hard to argue that
nuclear weapons in some long-term way
will preserve life they seem only only
able to potentially destroy it or at
best do do nothing at all
conflict that said
um we what is the role
at the sort of more medium-term society
level of some of these systems that seem
to run very contrary to to life
so there's a principle in the book uh
that i call poppers principle named
after the philosopher of science karl
popper and it basically says that
problems create progress
so you mentioned world war ii and it was
a terrible time a lot of bad things
happened but that same time period
produced the computer and information
technology and the computer was kind of
a need uh to do a couple of things uh
people have seen a movie about alan
turing where the computer was used to
crack uh enigma the nazi code yep and uh
the computer was also used
to try to create uh
uh nuclear weapons
um by von neumann and others
so you do get this kind of paradoxical
thing where
you have technology that has uh terrible
uses and really good uses
so
it does seem
a little bit contradictory but not when
you realize that it's the problems that
uh we face
that pushes us to find solutions and
pushes us in the direction of progress
mass extinctions uh
basically if you look at the the the
trend uh as far as like biological
complexity and diversity after every
mass extinction uh the biosphere went to
new levels of complexity and diversity
so it's like uh life adapts and evolves
and evolves uh because it has challenges
so
this will lead people to kind of
question this
idea of progress because they you know
see all these things going on these
mounting existential challenges
like climate change and the threat of
nuclear war rising income inequality uh
but it is precisely those challenges
that uh push us to uh find solutions
that ultimately lead to progress now
that doesn't mean
we ignore the like so for example
someone might hear that and say hey
listen based on what bobby said
we just shouldn't worry about climate
change because even if it is as
destructive as the worst hypotheses say
it is
eventually life will persist and things
will just kind of like reorder
themselves and everything will be okay
but it sounds like what you're saying is
these are opportunities for humans to do
things and to figure out solutions yes
so that thing that you said earlier
would be like the the the worst way to
interpret this yes uh we can't the
process doesn't happen on its own and it
goes back to
uh the point that we're part of this
process yes so we need to try uh our
very best to overcome these solutions if
not we will be
the errors that get corrected by natural
selection and the people who come after
us or the uh you know species or
civilization that comes after us
uh will uh do something different uh
hopefully they'll learn from our
mistakes but yeah it's this process of
continually learning from failure right
and uh yeah we we have to do everything
in our power to overcome these
existential challenges
and uh one thing that this uh theory uh
kind of um shows about society is that
societies work in a very similar way uh
as organisms organisms biological
organisms so you are an organism and you
usually think about that as being one
single thing but you're a collective of
cells right working together in an
integrated fashion your brain is a
collection of 80 billion neurons all
connected by 10 000 connections each
and the
output of that collective computation is
your intelligent behavior and your
productivity so you can look at a
society as being a social organism and
you can even look at the network of
humans that spans the planet as forming
something like a global brain uh because
of the internet and social media and now
blockchain systems uh connecting us in a
very similar way
and
if we want to overcome our existential
challenges we have to use the full
computational power
of the global brain and this gives us
some principles for how to optimize
our social political and economic
systems so on that note in the limited
time we have left
all of this if we go down to kind of
like the nitty gritty level
what are the immediate things that in
human society could be done
as you see it to better orient ourselves
towards this future and this could be
regulating social media passing some
laws about carbon i mean really like if
we just were to say what what are the
bullet points of things that could be
done
by governments and organizations at this
point to better serve our future is
there a sort of short list
uh yes uh there's a long list and a
short list so everything that you know
people are like fighting for right now
those are are you know worthy things
that uh we should be tackling but uh
there are some uh more basic principles
that come from complexity science which
just tells us uh how to get the maximum
amount of computational power out of a
system so uh computational power is a
function of how complex a system is a
system is more complex if there are more
components and there are more
connections between those components and
you also want a variety
of different types of components so
we want to be connected in
you know a way similar to how
neurons are connected in the brain
so
uh any nation that uh cuts their people
off from the internet is stopping that
free flow of information
and the free the free flow of
information allows for greater social
awareness and knowledge exchange
so you know countries like north korea
russia china that are doing that that's
not intrinsically good for a complex
adaptive system in the long run
the other thing i mentioned was the need
for diversity among components so the
human body
has over 200 cell types because they're
doing a division of labor a society of
all doctors or society of all engineers
or musicians uh wouldn't do well so we
need a specialization because it allows
for a division of labor
and uh we so we need diversity and
not just cultural diversity but a
diversity of ideas
so
any system any nation that doesn't allow
for criticism of the current system
that's also intrinsically bad because
you want new ideas that challenge the
status quo
that's sort of how
progress happens too
the last thing that i would say is
income inequality so we're seeing levels
of income inequality uh higher than
we've ever seen before
and that means all of the resources are
concentrated in these small pockets so
that would be so if society is a social
organism that would be like all of the
resources like the blood the nutrients
all
um in certain areas and not systemically
flowing right to all the appendages and
if that is the case
then uh ultimately that superorganism
will die because those parts will fester
and then affect uh the rest of the body
so we want to uh
have a way to kind of redistribute these
resources i don't think like a communist
model or like a
socialist model is necessarily the best
way to do that because
um you don't want like a government with
all this power like calling the shots
you want some sort of uh natural
way to do that and um
i think the decentralization movement
made popular by cryptocurrencies and
bitcoin uh is a way to do that
because uh nfts will allow uh for a new
crowdfunding mechanism that will allow
you know normal people to
raise money for a business project and
then the people who are
uh donating to that project like they
would kickstarter they actually become
investors right um so there's a lot of
creative ways you know and
to think about how to structure society
maybe we need some optimal balance
between socialist and capitalist
policies uh decentralization could
provide you know new ideas about how to
find that balance
uh but yeah we need to look at how
nature has optimized systems through
evolutionary processes
uh
to kind of
teach us how to best optimize society
we've been speaking with cognitive
neuroscientist and blogger bobby azarian
the new book is the romance of reality
how the universe organizes itself to
create life consciousness and cosmic
complexity bobby always a pleasure
having you on
thank you so much david and
congratulations on being a new father
thank you